hello good evening bosu bonsoir you see
Steve Kaufman Steve Kaufman here i am
going to be traveling to France labelled
foss i leave on thursday evening i'll be
traveling mostly on my wood business but
jihad yonghong continos am imam of the
link ma'am hamamoto link may dijon ddm
upon day long ap someplace uncle
telethon to Joe VA the 30th of January
meet up on called Apache a lollicock
isn't a TI SE ven dkc sue monk analicia
youtube p 0 wat pho van agua so if
you're interested let me know and we'll
find a place well I society don't in
opportunity honk already the junkie sin
ti so long so I look forward to hearing
from you by the way I'm going to be in
Mexico from februari 26 to March
thirteenth the first seven or eight days
in San Miguel de Allende and guanajuato
which is not very far from Guadalajara I
can take a bus over there podemos
encontrarnos agua la jara entre ellos
saben TCA digamos la primera semana de
marzo y despues seria en la ciudad de
mexico yo no se el día es esta el tres a
de marzo entonces podemos tambien
encontrarnos en la tio de mexico
entonces si amigos mexicanos que viven
ocn valla ha no se en la ciudad de
mexico por favor que indica que solo los
gatos a que podemos tratar de organizer
la una una encuentro en cual ahora un
otro en
not your amigo mucho gusto merci
beaucoup nice chatting with you all here
via de su unilateral method of
communication so I hope that in Paris
and eventually in Mexico we'll have some
more opportunity for some chitchat back
and forth in different languages thank
you for listening bye for now